I'm extremely sorry that we've had to
take this decision Neal Woodford was a
city star with a reputation for beating
the markets that persuaded around
300,000 people to invest almost 3
billion pounds in funds in his name
Andy Essex was one of them a retired
civil servant he invested 23 thousand
pounds in the funds but when Woodford's
luck ran out last summer and his fund
was suspended and then closed and he
could only watch as he lost around six
thousand pounds the price of it has just
gone down and down in the last week it's
gone down over five percent and I think
it's gone down about 25-30 percent since
the fund were closed and not being able
to talk to you money and you know cut
your losses extremely frustrated
ordinary investors will discover exactly
how much they've lost this week and
they'll be counting the cost here in
Kent where the local authority pension
fund representing a hundred and
thirty-five thousand frontline staff had
more than 260 million pounds invested
with Woodford when they tried to get it
out last summer he couldn't raise the
money forcing the fun to close and
trapping investors we are looking at
probably a loss from that pension fund
of around about 16 million pounds about
23% of the overall investment now the
party line from here has been that is a
small proportion of the overall
population holder on the street I don't
think that they would see 60 million
pounds a small change while investors
have watched their assets shrink Neal
Woodford and his business partner
continued to pay themselves millions in
dividends that's helped fund a lavish
lifestyle including a country estate in
Gloucestershire but he is reluctant to
answer questions could I speak to Neal
Woodford please not at home it would
seem mr. Watford has said he doesn't
want to be interviewed about what
happened with his fund but he could face
questions soon from the financial
conduct authority they have opened an
investigation Neal Woodford is not alone
in profiting from helping
people exploit new investment
opportunities but this former city
minister believes the current system
doesn't protect small retail investors
people were allowed to cash in their
defying pension pension scheme and go
off and make their own investments and
I'm sure the history is going to come to
tell us that this will be the creation
of the biggest ever opportunity for
mis-selling of financial instruments has
Neal Woodford lost it
Neal Woodford believes his investments
would have come good in time but those
who lost money will tell you past
success really is no guide to future
performance Paul Kelso Sky News